Lola texted me when we were going in
about the set the scandival episode
um and she said you better watch
yourself
Mark Consuelos revealing his daughter
Lola warned him about talking scandaval
on live TV
I can't either no turning back now yeah
no turning back again there was no
turning back for Mark or his wife Kelly
Ripa after they addressed scandaval on
their morning talk show Live with Kelly
and Mark you don't that's bad there's so
many other women to have affairs with
[Music]
rookie mistake dude yeah never ever ever
the sister and then a close second never
ever the best friend and those can
probably go either way all right maybe
you still realize that I'm getting such
a window into who Martin
yeah you know Scandal the cultural
phenomenon that's been playing out for
months on Vanderpump Rules after it was
revealed Tom Sandoval had an affair with
his longtime partner Ariana maddox's
best friend Raquel Levis kind of feels
like you're the most hated man on
television right now yeah
fast forward to Tuesday and Mark was a
guest on Watch What Happens Live where
naturally conversation turned to
scandival and how his daughter Lola was
the one who got him hooked she really
educated the family she made us watch it
she made us watch it what you said we're
doing two things tonight we're watching
scandival
and the the episode and then we're gonna
watch the first episode of The Reunion
clearly Mark and Kelly watched and like
the rest of us became fascinated the
girl who's got cheated on I understand
you're crying you're crying like that
you're upset but then the friends would
come over and they would start crying
like crying harder than the woman that
was cheated on is very complicated but
it did seem from my perspective
exhausting to have to console all of
your friends who are there to console
yeah Mark was asked by a fan if any of
his kids give him and Kelly feedback
about their show and that's when he
revealed Lola's very specific criticism
Lola texted me when we were going in
about the set the scandival episode
um and she said you better watch
yourself
she said you better watch what side
you're taking because it could go very
bad for you right yeah so uh yeah so
that was one one of the latest times
that our kids checked in my daughter I
am the most impressed with her ability
to really speak about what she needs
when she needs it and she
unapologetically does that so it begs
the question will Lola's warning stop
her parents from Talking Punk rules on
TV don't you think that he was just
trying to get out of this relationship
he had no yes he obviously chose the
person that would blow up the
relationship well yeah it doesn't seem
like it Mark's already predicting what
will happen when Raquel joins part 3 of
the Season reunion I know I don't think
there's no hope for her I think she's
gonna apologize a lot and we're all
going to yell at her and she's gonna
apologize some more James and Lala can't
talk because they
did it's not the same thing shut the
up everyone had things to say I've
now done you know hundreds of reunions
so yeah I would say this is going to be
this is going to be top 10.
foreign
[Music]